welcome everyone to what I'm calling
Christmas with Meister eart this is
something that I've been wanting to do
since um you know we we all love Meister
eart here on the channel and of course
he is famous among other things for
doing his Christmas or Advent sermons
for for the Christmas season we did read
one of those sermons a few years ago go
but um there are more than one so um the
idea here is to do a kind of Series
where once every week on on Sunday we
will read one of those sermons and and
finishing off on hopefully on Christmas
Eve and today at least when I'm
recording this today is the first of
Advent and Advent is
this um period in in in waiting for for
the the the birth of of Christ in
Christianity right it's it's it's from
the the the fourth Sunday before
Christmas until Christmas Eve is called
Advent and this is a time of usually of
fasting and contemplation again in sort
of preparation for for Christmas when
when Christians will celebrate the the
the birth of of Jesus or of
Christ so and again you know I'm
recording this on Sunday but probably I
won't be able to edit this in time so
I'm sorry that this first one is not
like actually on the Sunday but
hopefully the the coming um videos will
be on time on on each Sunday um and we
will be reading uh some of those me
echart sermons that are so fascinating
and so
beautiful um just to make things even
more dramatic and and
U special uh we're of course going
to we're going to light the Advent
candle the first one here so one every
every week until Christmas um let's see
I only have one have one chance to do
this that's the first
[Music]
one there we
go for all the sweets out there I feel
like on Aisa right now um I thought this
would be a this would be a a a cozy and
nice way to to celebrate the Christmas
season this year with the great C
Catholic uh
frier uh doin Dominican frier even
philosopher Mystic Theologian Meister
ekot from Germany um Meister eot
was all of those things he was from from
Germany from from what is known as
the well it's in the region of the Ryan
river right so he's one of the so-called
Rin land Mystics alongside others like
Hill thegarden you know Henry suzo and
Toler and all these people um eart is is
very famous for his very daring
philosophical ideas he lived between the
13th century to um he died in in
1328 and his ideas like he
was a prominent figure in the Dominican
church he was a professor or he was a a
master as his name suggests in in the
university in Paris he taught at that
University he also taught in Cologne in
different places so he was a prominent
figure uh and he would preach and and
and write works of philosophy and
Theology and in particular his preaching
was was really what one of the things
that he was most famous for especially
his preaching in his native language
which was Middle High German and and
those those sermons in German in Middle
High German have survived and those are
also often the most profound ones
because he uses the German language in
such a creative way way rather than
using the sort of lurgical language of
Latin which was the most common and he
does use Latin in his written works um
when he preaches um he uses Middle High
German he's able to sort of use that
language in such a fascinating and
beautiful way he come ups with new words
for things and just it's really amazing
and one or I should one series of those
sermons in German was held there are
four of them they were held in Christmas
season and as I understand it they were
held
on each Sunday of of Advent until
Christmas Eve um I'm not sure what the
audience was it doesn't seem like this
was one of those sermons for the general
public but perhaps for a more select
group of of you know maybe monks or nuns
because he's speaking about things that
are more advanced let's say in that
sense um so
eart again a prom minent figure but also
a controversial one because ehart had
some very daring ideas and we talked
about this in our full video on ehart
which you can check out but also briefly
in our previous episode where we read
one of these
sermons in that the basic
idea of Art's philosophy Bernard mcin
talks about the the core of Art's
thought as he calls it the mysticism of
the ground and eart
talks particularly about this Concept in
German called the grun which is what
it's translated as the ground uh the
grun it's not ground just in the sense
of being like something you walk on
grunt also means things like Foundation
Essence um core like the most
foundational core of something or or
origin of something you mean all these
different things and and what I would
say at least is that the core of of e
Art's philosophy is this idea that the
ground of the soul of the human being
being and the ground of God is one and
the same ground and that's a really
profound idea right
um some would call it a kind of
non-dualism I'm careful with those kinds
of terms but certainly there's this idea
that that that the ground of God is the
ground of all things go God is
identified with being and the being of
all things and all things other than God
are nothingness right and we recognize
this from many other mystical
philosophers as
well and this philosophy and we'll get
into the details of some of these things
as we read
but these philosophies of eart or this
mystical theology or whatever you want
to refer to it as comes out in these
amazing Christmas sermons that he that
he that he held back then um in
particular when it comes to Christmas
eart has a pretty unique perspective and
again we talked about this in our
earlier video talking about you know
Christmas according to my eart but Art's
view on
Christmas is certainly uh focused on the
metaphysical you could say um Christmas
celebrates the birth of Jesus the birth
of Christ and he recognizes of course
that that is what the celebration is
about on a surface level it's about the
birth of the human Christ but he doesn't
focus on that right his whole thing is
focusing rather on the
metaphysical um implications and aspects
of that uh what is the birth of Christ
it is the birth of the
son to the father right the birth of the
word as it is said in in the Gospel of
John right in the beginning was the word
and the Word was with God and the Word
was God the word or logos is identified
with the son with Christ so he uses
these terms the birth of the son or the
birth of the word um and this birth not
only takes place in history with the
human Christ but uh it is the birth
birth um of the Sun in the Trinity which
take place eternally in the Eternal
present it is something that happens
before creation Before
Time um and thus it is profoundly
according art taking place right now the
birth of the son um in the Divine ground
so to say and remember also that we said
that according to eart the ground of God
and the ground of the soul is one and
the same ground which means that the
birth of the sun is taking place in the
depths of the soul of the human being as
well and so the mystical journey is this
process of of stripping away detaching
all thing yourself from all things from
all individuality from all multiplicity
all these uh external things until you
sort of penetrate into that ground the
silent complete darkness the nothingness
the unknowing of the ground of the soul
and there when we break through and he
he uses a term in German which I cannot
remember at the moment sadly he comes
comes up with a term of his own actually
that is often translated as detaching or
sorry of of breaking
through um and when we break through we
go beyond you know multiplicity and
Duality Beyond even the concept of God
into the ground and in that ground in
that silence we thus experience that
birth of the sun within ourselves and
that is the sort of symbol of the utmost
um mystical experience right so that is
to Echo out what what Christmas is about
and there are several Dimensions to that
it's the birth of the of the son in in
in God right or birth of the Sun
metaphysically in the Eternal present
it's also uh the
birth our birth in God as the son as we
are all sons and children of God it's
the birth of God in ourselves in a
certain sense um because again the
ground of the soul and the ground of God
is one in the same ground and so that
birth take place within our ourselves it
is part of our own ground our own being
and so these themes are all sort of
interwoven in these in these sermons so
you know um that's I think um a good
amount of background for us to sort of
dive into the text itself we're going to
be using uh the translations by Maurice
o c Walsh from this beautiful volume of
the complete works of Meister eart uh
and of course we're going to begin we're
going to be Beginning by by reading the
first of of the
sermons um and this first sermon is
really interesting in many ways it's to
me at least it's the clearest one he is
very clear in his argumentation he's
very clear um in different ways and and
fascina this sermon through his
discussion about this birth of the word
and the bth you know Christmas he
basically
summarizes so many aspects of his
thought at the same time so as we go
through you'll see that all these themes
if especially if you if You' read Master
eart before or you watched my full video
on his philosophy you'll see that like
many of those sort of Cornerstone
features of his thought comes up in this
sermon in different
ways um which hopefully you'll see um my
idea here is that I will read the sermon
and I will also be stopping and sort of
giving short comments on what's going on
sometimes I'm trying that out this first
time if you guys don't like that and you
want me to just read through the whole
thing then let me know in the comments
and maybe I'll I'll change that for for
next time but I think it could be
helpful also to have um some some sort
of comments some some context to what's
going on or clarifications of certain
things not that I'm some sort of you
know expert on on eart in particular but
um I think it could be helpful for some
people
so without further Ado uh let's begin
reading the first sermon of me eot
delivered sometime 700 years ago uh
on maybe not on this very day but around
this season this Christmas season so
many years ago and they you know even
though it was so long ago um at least to
me regardless of your sort of religious
affiliation and you guys know that mine
is complicated right but um uh
regardless these words really have a
profound impact on on many people as
they read it so here is the first sermon
of Misa eart in his sort of Christmas
series of
sermons here in time we are celebrating
the Eternal birth which God the Father
bore and bears unceasingly in eternity
because this same birth is now born in
time in human nature St Augustin says
what does it Avail me that this birth is
always happening if it does not happen
in me that it should happen in me is
what matters we shall therefore speak of
this birth of how it may take place in
us and be consummated in The Virtuous
Soul whenever God the Father speaks his
eternal word in the perfect soul for
what I say here is to be understood of
the good and perfected man who has
walked and is still walking in the ways
of God not of the natural undisciplined
man for he is entirely remote from and
totally ignorant of this
birth so this is why I'm saying that
this sermon probably aimed at people who
are more on a sort of more mystical
dedicated path perhaps monks or nuns for
example those are the kinds of people um
who are able to have this experience or
this this go on this path because it is
a difficult path uh only meant for for
for certain people so to
say there is a saying of the wise man
when all things lay in the midst of of
Silence then there descended down into
me from on high from the Royal Throne a
secret word this sermon is about that
word so this is the Bible quote this is
uh the quote that that the whole sermon
sort of revolves around three things are
to be noted here the first is where in
the soul God the Father speaks his word
where this birth takes place and where
she is receptive of this act for that
can only be in the very purest loftiest
subtlest part that the soul is capable
of in very truth if God the father in
his omnipotence could endow the soul
with anything more noble and if the soul
could have received from him anything
nobler then the father would have had to
delay the birth for the coming of this
greater
Excellence therefore the soul in which
this birth is to take place must keep
absolutely pure and must live in Noble
fashion quite collected and turned
entirely inward not not running out
through the Five Senses Into the
multiplicity of
creatures but all inurned and collected
and in the purest part there is his
place he disdains anything
less the second part of this sermon has
to do with man's conduct in relation to
this act to God's speaking of his word
within to this birth whether it is more
profitable for man to cooperate with it
so that it may come to pass in him
through his own exerion and Merit by a
man's creating in himself a mental image
in his thoughts and disciplining himself
that way by reflecting that God is wise
omnipotent Eternal or whatever else he
can imagine about God whether this is
more profitable and conductive to this
birth from the father or whether one
should shun and free oneself from all
thoughts words and deeds and from all
images created by the understanding
maintaining a holy God receptive
attitude such that one's own self is
Idol letting God work within
one which conduct conduces best to this
birth the third point is the profit and
how great it is which acrs from this
birth note in the first place that in
what I'm about to say I shall make use
of natural proofs so that you yourselves
can grasp that it is so for though I put
more faith in the scriptures than in
myself yet it is easier and better for
you to learn by means of arguments that
can be verified this is the the
philosopher in eart speaking right using
arguments and and and and and you know
proofs to to sort of get at what he's
saying first we will take the words in
the midst of Silence there was spoken
within me a secret
word but sir where is the silence and
where is the place where the word is
spoken as I said just now it is in the
purest thing that the soul is capable of
in the noblest part the ground indeed in
the very essence of the Soul which is
the Soul's most secret part there is the
silent middle for no creature ever
entered there and no image nor has the
soul there either activity or
understanding therefore she is not aware
there of any image whether of herself or
of any other
creature whatever the soul affects she
affects with her powers what she
understands she understands with the
intellect what she remembers she does
with memory if she would love she does
that with the will and that she works
with her powers and not with her Essence
every external Act is linked with some
means the power of sight Works only
Through The Eyes otherwise it can
neither employ nor bestow a vision and
so it is with all the other senses the
Soul's every external Act is affected by
some means but in the Soul's Essence
there is no activity for the power she
works with emanate from the ground of
being yet in that ground is the silent
middle here nothing but rest and
celebration for this birth this act that
God the Father may speak his word there
for this part is by nature receptive to
nothing save only the Divine Essence
without
mediation here God enters the soul with
his all not merely with a part god
enters here the ground of the Soul none
can touch the ground of the soul but God
Alone no creature can enter the Soul's
ground but must stop outside in the
powers so to clarify here he's talking
about the fact that um the ground is
this utter Simplicity that is sort of
Beyond knowledge of outside things right
or rather when the soul knows things it
knows it through images through things
externally right so we uh when I know
this lamp I see see it with my eyes so
my eyes take it in and then that leaves
a sort of imprint or image on my mind so
everything comes from outside uh
knowledge of God or or you know the
grace of God is not reached through this
way rather it is reached through the
ground of the Soul or in the ground of
the Soul which is beyond these senses
and these kinds of images in the ground
there is no image there is no form
there's there's nothing right so echar
talks about the ground as as a kind of
utter nothingness it's not a can't it's
not knowing it's unknowing and he like
he takes this a lot from pseudo dianus
of course if you're familiar with him um
that in this ground there is just
complete silence and darkness he calls
it a nothingness even but in a literal
sense a no thingness there is nothing
there and that is where God can sort of
speak and and he literally says that he
enters the ground of the Soul here as we
saw though God is like the ground of God
is the ground of the soul and that is is
why he can enter there because there is
no mediation it is a kind of direct
presence and and knowledge that is
beyond image or word or anything just a
kind of direct ontological existential
unity and direct apprehension and
presence of God so that's the difference
here right uh between knowing things
externally through the powers as he says
and knowing things in the ground which
is a direct immediate uh knowing if we
can call that a knowing direct immediate
Unknowing
which is a sort of direct um Union with
God in a certain
sense within the soul sees clearly the
image whereby the creature has been
drawn in and taken lodging for whenever
the powers of the Soul make contact with
the creature they set to work and make
an image and the likeness of the
creature which they obsorb that is how
they know the creature no creature can
come closer to the soul than this and
the soul never approaches a creature
without having first voluntarily taken
an image of it into herself through this
presented image the soul approaches
creatures an image being something that
the soul makes of external objects with
her own powers whether it is a stone a
horse a man or anything else that she
wants to know she gets out the image of
it that she has already taken in and is
thus enabled to unite herself with it
but for a man to receive an image in
this way it must of necessity enter from
without through the senses in
consequence there is nothing so unknown
to the soul as herself accordingly one
master says that the soul can neither
create nor obtain an image of
herself therefore she has no way of
knowing herself for images all enter
through the senses and hence she can
have no image of herself and so she
knows all other things but not herself
of nothing does she know so little as of
herself for want of
mediation this is interesting because we
can connect it to other um ideas in
other um schools of thought such as in
um different forms of of Hindu or H like
indic thought like vidanta for example
they talk about self- knowledge as a
sort of
pure absolute knowledge that is just
apparent to everyone we all know
ourselves but at the same time the self
is that which we know the least about
which could we cannot know anything
about the self because the self is pure
subjectivity and as eart talks about
here um when we have knowledge of things
it's all external things coming into to
our awareness and leaving an image on
the soul uh but the soul has no there's
there's nothing external like the soul
is not external to the soul right it's
just our self our soul and so we can
have we can't have that kind of
knowledge of ourselves that we have of
other things in other words if we Define
knowledge in that sense that we usually
do then we know nothing about ourselves
we know nothing about our soul and that
is what he's saying here although we can
also sort
of um assume that we do have a kind of
we have some sort of knowledge of
ourselves that we forget but that's the
knowledge we get when we we when we
break through back into that ground and
which at which point we get a kind of
knowledge if we can call it knowledge
again of ourselves as United to the
ground of the Divine
right that is that is how I read this
any anyway
um let's continue and you must know too
that inwardly the soul is free and void
of all means and all images which is why
God can free freely Unite with her
without form or
likeness whatever power you ascribe to
any Master you cannot but ascribe that
power to God without limit the more
skilled and Powerful the master the more
immediately is is his work affected and
the simpler it is man requires many
means for his external works much
preparation for the of the material is
needed before he can produce them as he
has imagined them but the sun in its
Sovereign Mastery performs its task
which is to give light very swiftly the
instant its Radiance is poured forth the
ends of the Earth are full of
light more exalted is the Angel who
needs still less means for his work and
has fewer images
the highest Sara has but a single image
he seizes as a unity all that his
inferiors regard as manifold but God
needs no image and he has no image
without any means likeness or image God
operates in the soul right in the ground
where no image ever got in but only he
himself with his own being this no
creature can do how does God the Father
give birth to a son in the soul like
creatures in images and likenesses no by
my faith but just as he gives birth to
him in eternity no more no less well but
how does he give birth to him then now
see God the father has a perfect insight
into himself profound and thorough
knowledge of himself by himself and not
through any image and thus God the
father gives birth to his son in the
true Unity of the divine nature see it
is like this and in no other way that
God the father gives birth to the son in
the ground and essence of the soul and
thus unites himself with her for if any
image were present there would be no
real Union and in that real Union lies
the Soul's whole beatitude so here we
get to that central idea of earts of the
Union of the ground of the soul and the
ground of God right so we see already we
see some of those key features of his
thought present in this sermon revolving
around you know the theme of Christmas
and the birth of the
son
now you might say there is by nature
nothing in the soul but images not at
all if that were so the soul could never
become blessed for God cannot make any
creature from which you can receive
perfect blessedness otherwise God would
not be the highest blessing and the
final goal whereas it is his nature to
be this and it is his will to be the
Alpha and Omega of all things no
creature can constitute your blessedness
nor can it be your Perfection here on
Earth for the perfection of this life
which is the sum of all the virtues is
followed by the Perfection of the life
to come therefore you have to be and
dwell in the essence and in the ground
and there God will touch you with his
simple Essence without the intervention
of any image no image represents and
signifies itself it always aims and
points that of which it is the image and
since you have no image but of what is
outside yourself which is drawn in
through the senses and continually
points to that which of of which it is
the image therefore it is impossible for
you to be beatified by any image
whatsoever so I read a kind of platonic
uh thing here right any everything is a
is an image that that points to that of
which it is the image um and and the
image themselves can never
um you can never be beatified by an
image he says you can only be beatified
by that of which it is the image and
ultimately and I might be reading
platonic ideas and maybe like akbarian
ideas into this here but it seems to me
at least that ultimately the the the
thing of which everything is an image is
at the end of the day God right so and
that seems to fit into what the point
he's making is that only God can
accomplish that nothing other than God
can do
that we
continue and therefore there must be a
silence and a Stillness and the father
must speak in that and give birth birth
to his son and perform his Works free
from all
images the second point is what must a
man contribute by his own actions in
order to procure and deserve the
occurrence and the consummation of this
birth in himself is it better to do
something towards this to imagine and
think about God or should he keep still
and Silent in peace and quiet and let
God speak and work in him merely Waiting
for God to
act so I think the question he's asking
is pretty self-explanatory right are we
participating in this process of of sort
of uniting with the ground so to say
or is it rather a sort of complete
passivity where we just fall away from
ourselves and let God sort of pour forth
his his grace into us or is there some
kind of to to to put it in a crude way
is there some kind of philosophizing
involved
here now I say as I said before that
these words and this act are only for
the good and perfected people who have
so absorbed and assimilated the essence
of all virtues that these virtues
emanate from them naturally without
their seeking and above all there must
dwell in them the worthy life and lofty
teachings of our Lord Jesus Christ they
must know that the very best and noblest
attainment in this life is to be silent
and let God work and speak within when
the powers have been completely
withdrawn from all their works and
then the word is spoken remember that
word and son is synonymous in Christian
theology so again this word is the son
being born in the soul right therefore
he said in the midst of the silence the
secret word was spoken unto me again
going back to that Bible verse that the
whole thing revolves around and so the
more completely you were able to draw in
your powers to a unity and forget all
those things and their images which you
have absorbed and the further further
you can get from creatures and their
images the nearer you are to this and
the reer to receive it if only you could
suddenly be unaware of all things then
you could pass into an oblivion of your
own body as St Paul did when he said
whether in the body I cannot tell or out
of the body I cannot tell God knows
it so this is interesting we go back to
that idea of Unknowing right um this
knowing that we're trying to reach of
our of our true selves as the you know
the union of the ground of God and the
Soul can only be done by detaching from
all other things or from all things
really everything that is a thing needs
to be detached from whether that is
creatures or images or or idea of
ourselves our soul even our idea of God
right this is a recurring thing in in
eart right we should get rid of all of
our thoughts our ideas all the knowledge
we think we have until we just
everything is just complete nothingness
and silence
only then he says here right only then
can God speak the word and the Soul this
very a key key thing to understand about
eart and very profound
right in this case the spirit had so
entirely absorbed the powers that it had
forgotten the body memory no longer
function nor understanding nor the
senses nor the powers that should
function so as to govern and Grace the
body vital warmth and body heat were
suspended so that the body did not waste
during the 3 days when he neither ate
nor drank thus too Moses fared when he
fasted for 40 days in the mountain and
was none the worse for it for on the
last day he was as strong as on the
first in this way a man should flee his
senses turn his powers Inward and sink
into an oblivion of all things and
himself concerning this a master dressed
the soul thus with the draw from the
unrest of external activities then flee
away and hide from the turmoil of inward
thoughts for they but create
Discord so this is the kind of image or
the the kind of imagery that we all love
about eart right which he gets of course
from people like pudus but still this
idea of he says turn his powers Inward
and sink into an oblivion of all things
in himself this is such powerful
language to me right this idea of just
and and he is unique like this is a
common thing we find in
mysticism generally defined right of
sort of turning away from ourselves of
of of annihilating the ego and so on but
um few people use this kind of such
strong and powerful imagery as people
like eart and pudus where we're to sort
of just sink into an oblivion of all
things and of ourselves I just love this
kind of
language and so if God is to speak his
word in the soul she must be at rest and
at peace and then he will speak his word
and himself in the soul no image but
himself dianus and there he shows up of
course dianus says God has no image or
likeness of himself for he's
intrinsically all goodness truth and
being God performs all his Works whether
within himself or outside himself in a
flashh do not imagine that God when he
made Heaven and Earth and all things
made one thing one day and another the
next Moses describes it like that but he
really knew better he did so for the
sake of people who could not conceive or
grasp it any other
way all God did was this he willed he
spoke and they were so here of course
the classic sort of abrahamic thing of
God speaking the word into existence we
are reminded of of you know the first
words of Genesis uh God says you know
let there be light and there was light
and so on or even in the Quran where
where it says
um right so God only has to says be and
it is this very similar to what art is
saying here we continue God works
without means and without images and the
Freer you are from images the more
receptive you are for his inward working
and the more introverted and self
forgetful the nearer you are to this
dianus exhorted his pupil Timothy in
this sense saying Dear Son Timothy do
you with untroubled mind soar above
yourself and all your powers above R
ration and reasoning above Works above
all modes and existence into the secret
still darkness that you may come to the
knowledge of the Unknown super Divine
God there must be a withdrawal from all
things God scorns to work through
images now you might say what does does
God do without images in the ground and
Essence that I cannot know because my
sole Powers receive only in images they
have to know when lay hold of each thing
in its appropriate image they cannot
recognize a horse when presented with
the image of a man and since all these
enter from without that knowledge is
hidden from my soul which is to her
great
Advantage this not knowing makes her
wonder and leads her to eager Pursuit
for she perceives clearly that it is but
does not know how or what it is whenever
a man knows the causes of things then he
at once tires of them and seeks to know
something different always clamoring to
know things is forever Inc constant and
so this unknown knowing keeps the soul
constant and yet Spurs her on to Pursuit
this is also a very interesting and
profound section here and it reminds me
of another one of Art's famous sermons
it's one that my friend Justin Sledge
and I often talk about um and it's this
sermon where he talks about Hunger of
this kind of that that and you know not
literally hunger of course but this kind
of hunger where the more you eat the
hungrier you get that this is the case
with with with God right the the more
you eat of of I can't remember the
exact thing he talks about in that
sermon
but just to paraphrase right the more
you eat of of of this this Divine path
or this ground the hunger you get right
so as opposed to all other kinds of
knowledge when you when you when you're
curious about something you want to know
something when you find out how things
work in this case he says the cause of
things then you you're kind of done
seeking that thing out you're not
imagine if you
knew so in my case imagine if I just
suddenly learned everything about
religion or religious studies just every
I just had all the answers now suddenly
there would be very little reason for me
to keep seeking for you know keep
studying I would probably have to just
go you know study something else that
that's that's more interesting in that
case because you know I know everything
so then
suddenly you know it becomes
uninteresting and and he's saying here
that um when it comes to to to knowing
your soul in a true sense like this this
is not the case um he says and I re I
will reread the last section here and so
this unknown knowing keeps the soul
constant and yet Spurs her on to Pursuit
so this path is is unending in a certain
sense uh which also reminds us of uh one
of the key early church fathers Gregory
of Nissa who also talks about this Union
with God which is not this idea of no
you go on the path and then you you
become United with God and then you're
just you you're done right you're United
with God that is not the case to be
United with God is to travel
eternally it's a sort of Eternal
traveling that never stops because God
after all is infinite than Eternal so
that even when you're United with God
that sort of that journey within God is
eternal in itself I'm not sure that's
exactly what he's referring to here but
that certainly comes to
mind uh let's continue about this the
wise man said in the middle of the night
when all things were in a quiet silence
there was spoken to me a hidden word it
came like a thief by stealth why does he
call it a word when it was hidden the
nature of a word is to reveal what is
hidden it revealed itself to me and
Shone forth before me declaring
something to me and making God known to
me and therefore it is called a word yet
what it was remained hidden from
me that was its stealthy coming in a
whispering Stillness to reveal itself
see just because it is hidden one must
and should always pursue it it Shone
forth and yet was hidden we're meant to
yearn and sigh for it St Paul exhorts us
to pursue this until we aspy it and not
to stop until we grasp
it after we had been caught up into the
third heaven where God was made known to
him and he beheld all things when he
returned he had forgotten nothing but it
was so deep down in his ground that his
intellect could not reach it it was
veiled from
him
so core feature of mysticism here right
in this case St Paul reaches the depths
of the soul in this case right he has
this mystical experience he has insight
into the nature of of God and or
reality when he comes back he has not
forgotten anything right he that that
truth is as clear as it ever was but he
cannot put it into words right the
intellect cannot grasp those things so
he cannot really you know there is no
way to put it into images and and if
anything is characteristic of mysticism
it would probably be this right it's
this idea that that reason and words are
limited especially when it comes to to
talking about these kinds of these kinds
of experiences RI in the beginning of
his mavi says you know that love cannot
be explained I cannot explain these
things and then he goes on for six books
to to explain it anyway in po but um so
that's the Paradox of mysticism
um that these are experiences that
cannot be explained and yet we have
these beautiful expressions like this
sermon or the masnavi or whatever it is
that that try in some way to if not
capture at least sort of point the way
to to
those realities
right we continue he therefore had to
pursue it and search for it in himself
and not outside it is all within not
outside but wholly within and knowing
this full well he said for I am
persuaded that neither death nor any
Affliction can separate me from what I
find within
me there is a fine saying of one Pagan
Master according to the footnotes we
don't know who he's referring to here
sadly but um there's a fine saying of
one Pagan Master to another about this
he said I am aware of something in me
which shines in my understanding I can
clearly perceive that it is something
but what it may be I cannot grasp yet I
think if I could only seize it I should
know all truth to which the other Master
replied follow it boldly for if you
could seize it you would possess the sum
total of all good and have eternal life
St Augustine spoke in the same sense
quote I am aware of something within me
that gleams and flashes before my soul
with this perfected and fully
established in me that would surely be
eternal life it hides yet shows itself
it comes but like a thief with intent to
take and steal all things from the soul
but by emerging and showing itself a
little it aims to lure the soul and draw
her toward itself to rob her and deprive
her of herself about this the prophet
says Lord take from them their spirit
and give them instead thy spirit this
too was meant by the loving soul when
she said my soul dissolved and melted
away when love SP spoke his word when he
entered I had to fall away and Christ
meant this by his words whoever abandons
anything for my sake shall be repaid H
hundredfold and whoever would possess me
must deny himself in all things and
whoever will serve me must follow me and
not go anymore after his
own just to go back there for a second
he says when he entered I had to fall
away right so
to again I'm using Sufi imagery here
because that's what I'm most comfortable
with as you know
but there's this famous Sufi story
where the Sufi poet in this case imagine
it might be room actually imagine
himself going up to the door of God by
knocking and God asks who's there and he
says you know it is
II or whatever and God says uh go away
you have no place here and he does this
a couple of times and he s
of um bewildered he's never LED inside
the store until finally and I'm I'm I'm
butchering the story but at the end he
comes to L again he knocks and God asks
again who is there he says no one and it
says now you have now you have earned
yourself the right to enter right um in
God in Union there cannot be any I right
there is only God in the ground of the
Soul there is
no speaking of myself but there's in the
ground of the Soul there is no FIP
there there's there's nothing there is
only God in this in this sense this is
how I read it he said when he entered I
had to fall away this is very again
another one of those themes that we find
not only in Christian mysticism or in
Sufism but all across these Traditions
that we sometimes refer to as mysticism
this idea of the mystical Union and this
mystical Union uh presupposes that the
self the eye has to disappear in order
for that Union to be
accomplished so let's continue here but
now you might say but good sir you want
to change the natural course of the soul
and go against her nature it is her
nature to take things in through the
senses and images would you upset this
ordering no but how do you know what
nobility God has bestowed upon human
nature not yet fully described and still
unrevealed for those who have written of
the Soul's nobility have gone nor
further than their natural intelligence
could carry them they had never entered
her ground so that much remained obscure
and unknown to them so the prophet said
I will sit in silence and hearken to
what God speaks within me because it is
so secret this word came in the night
and in darkness St John says the light
Shone in the darkness it came into its
own and as many as received it became in
Authority sons of God to them was given
power to become God's
Sons now observe the use and the fruits
of this secret word and this Darkness
the son of the heavenly father is not
born born alone in this darkness which
is his own you too can be born a child
of the same heavenly father and of none
other and to you he will give power now
observe how great the use is for all the
truth learned by all the Masters by
their own intellect and understanding or
ever to be learned till doomsday they
never had the slatest inkling of this
knowledge and this ground though it may
be called a nence an unknowing yet there
is in it more than in all knowing and
understanding without it for this
unknowing lurs in a racts you from all
understood things and from yourself as
well this is what Christ meant when he
said whoever will not deny himself and
will not leave his father and mother and
is not estranged from all these is not
worthy of me as though he were to say he
who does not abandon creaturely
externals can be neither conceived nor
born in this Divine birth so again that
same theme that we just
discussed but divesting yourself of
yourself and of everything external does
not truly give it to you and in very
truth I believe nay I am sure that the
man who is established in this cannot in
any way ever be separated from God I see
he can in no way lapse into mortal sin
he would rather suffer the most shameful
death as the Saints have done before him
than commit the least of mortal sins I
say such people cannot willingly commit
or consent to even a venial sin in
themselves or in others if they can stop
it and here we come to another one of
those famous themes in cart's thought
which is this um at least how I read it
is this idea of the Living Without A why
that the person who becomes United in
this way who reaches the ground and and
realizes the union of of the
ground so to say um his will becomes
United with the will of God we find this
both in aard very clearly but also
famously in margar pet in the mirror of
simple Souls um the will of the person
of the soul and the will of God becomes
one will and so that person
cannot sin in that case um pet this is
one of those things where both of these
figures were most sort of controversial
mostly criticized for it seems that they
they you could read this as as they
stating that you know once you reach
this state you don't have to perform the
the obligations of the religion you
don't have to pray you don't have to
give the Char you don't have to do all
these things
um or that you cannot commit a sin that
you're sort of of immune to sinning and
but that is not what they're saying this
is not what eart is saying here he's
saying that when when you realize the
Oneness of the ground your will becomes
the will of God and so in a certain
sance God acts through you right because
your will is United to the will of God
so your will is God's will and if your
will is God's will then of course you
cannot sin because God would never sin
and you're so you know to use modern
terminology you're so in tune with God
that there's no possibility of you
making
a sinful choice in your life right so
that that is that is the theme that he's
taking up here so again like I said in
the beginning so many of the the core
themes of Art's thought is is present
here and again that is that is one of
them we finish here so strongly are they
lured and drawn and accustomed to that
that they can never turn to any other
way to this way are directed all their
senses all their powers
May The God Who has been born again as
man assist us to this birth eternally
helping us weak men to be born in him
again as God
Amen so that that was the first sermon
of the amazing me eart for the Christmas
season the first Advent sermon I hope
you enjoy that um I think the sermon is
absolutely amazing uh it's so clear
sometimes reading people like they can
be you know dense and difficult this
sermon I don't feel is that dense at
least you know relatively right and also
because it's summarizes so well so many
aspects of his of his thought like we've
said and I hope you could also notice
that as we went through it um so that
was the first one next week um we're
going to read the second sermon and that
is a sermon that we already read a few
years ago so you know that's going to be
a a sort of a prise rerun for some of
you but um it's it's also a very
beautiful sermon so I don't think I
think most of you won't mind
experiencing that one
again um yeah so um I hope the Christmas
season so far is is treating you well
that it's it's meaningful in different
ways whether you are you know Christian
yourself if you're a Muslim whatever is
your worldview and your identity um you
know you either celebrate the Christmas
season or you don't but regardless I
hope um I hope life is treating you well
that you find a lot of meaning and and
Beauty in life uh because there is there
is all of that out there sometimes it
can be hard to see especially with all
the things happening in the world but
there is certainly Beauty uh and
goodness out there for if you know if
you can um if you if you know how and
where to look and uh reading some of
these uh philosophers and Mystics at
least to me it helps us sometimes sort
of tune into that um way of looking at
things where where Beauty becomes a
little more more apparent even in in in
very dark times and I
think that can be especially a powerful
message especially in the Christmas
season and especially like in a very
sort
of literal and and kind of surface level
way in in a in Scandinavia for example
here it's very dark in December right
and so any kind of lights that that um
any light that we can we can sort of uh
um find is something very beautiful and
useful so I hope you enjoyed this
reading let me know what you thought let
me know if you think this um uh this
format of of stopping and commenting on
things is good or if you think I should
just read through it and then we can I
don't know we can discuss the details in
the comments or something um but I look
forward to reading some more eart for
you in the coming weeks um again hope
the season is treating you
well and uh I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]